Welcome back everybody to
FP 101: Functional programming
and today we're going to talk about
types and classes.
As developers we often work
all-nighters. We sit and hack, we get into
a flow and we
lose track of time and so for developers
it's extremely important to watch our diet
to make sure that we eat well.
If you see the food pyramid here that
is shown in there, food
is grouped into categories. For example
you see bread, rice and pasta
which are carbohydrates and then you see
other things like proteins, fruits
and vegetables
etcetera. So all food
is put into groups
that have a common property and in some
sense
these groups what we can say is that
the food here is typed
and that's what this lecture will be
about: the lecture will be about
taking values (not food) but the values
that we code with
and how to group these into categories
that have similar properties. So what is
a type?
Well, a type is simply a name
for a collection of related values
just like a food group
is a name for a collection of
foods with related properties
and a type is a name for a collection of
values that we code with
that have similar properties. For example,
in Haskell the type Bool
is a name for a collection
that has two values: False and True. If we
would be
really really pedantic in Haskell
there would be a third
value Bottom and represents
non terminating computation of type Bool
but in this course as since we're going
to stick to the basics
we will ignore the more complicated
features
like Bottom, so and for now
we'll just say Bool is a type
that names the set of values
True and False, the boolean
values.
A type error is something where we are
using a function
with a type that
the function does not expect. Let's look
at the example here:
if we want to add 1 to False obviously
that's not going to work, because on the
left
we have a number and on the right we
have a boolean
and there's no way to add a number
to a boolean.
To go back to the example of diet
if you have a certain diet maybe
you're not allowed to mix meat
and dairy products, so that would be a
type error
in the food world. In the
programming world
we have the same kind of type errors.
The goal of static typing is that the
compiler will catch these type errors
early on, before we run the program
but there's also dynamically typed
languages where these type
errors are caught at runtime, so when
you're actually trying to
add up the boolean
with the number and then there's
non typed languages where this will just
take
however these two values are
represented
and it will try to add them up. The notation,
the syntax,
for writing down types in Haskell is
expression double colon type so if
evaluating the expression e will produce
a value of type t we write this
as e double colon t. Other languages
have different syntax, for example in Visual
Basic you will write
e as t and in Java
you would write t e
but that's all syntax. The real
thing is that we're
interested in the semantics of this
which says that
the type of expression e is t.
Now every well-formed expression, every
syntactically well-formed expression
has a type
and that type is calculated
by the compiler at compile-time
using a process called type inference.
Remember from the first lecture that
ML, the programming language ML
was one of the first programming languages
that had type inference. Type errors
are also in Haskell found at
compile-time and
in most programming languages are found
at compile-time and
the opinions differ about whether
you have to have static typing
or dynamic typing or optional typing
but for me, personally, I like it.
I'm lazy so I like it if the compiler
catches the
type errors for me early. In the previous
lecture we have played
around with GHC and GHC has a special command
colon type
that allows you to ask the type of
an expression so you can
ask GHC to calculate the type of an
expression for you.
For example, if we type in not False
GHC will calculate the value of that
not False equals True
but we can also ask for that type of not
False
and in which case it will not evaluate
that expression
but it will just calculate its type
The type of not False
is Bool.
Now we see that the value of not
False is True,
the type is Bool, so that's consistent.
GHC did a good job! It would be weird
and wrong if the type of not False would
be Integer,
but the value would be True. That is
called type soundness
which means that the type that the
compiler calculates
corresponds with the value that this
expression has
when you execute it at runtime. In Haskell
and most programming languages there are
a number of base types.
These are types that are built into
the language
and in Haskell there's a handful:
we have already seen Bool, the type
of a boolean value, True and False. Then
there's the type of character.
Char is the name of a set of values that
denote characters.
Char contains characters like
a b c
etcetera, all Unicode characters.
Then there's the type of String
which are strings of characters and we
will see later that in Haskell
strings are really nothing more than
lists of characters.
String, you could say is not
really a base type
because it's defined in terms of two
other base types: strings and characters.
Haskell is unique
or unique, Python has
similar properties
in that it has both Int and Integers.
Ints are fixed precision integers:
32-bit or 64-bit integers
and then Integer are arbitrary precision
integers. You can compute the factorial
of 500.
If you use type Integer that will
take a long time
but it will not overflow like
when you use Int. Then of course
there's Float,
the floating point numbers.
I mentioned when we talked about
characters I mentioned
that Strings really are lists of
characters and the type of lists
is the first generic type or polymorphic
type
that we will see in Haskell.
A List is a sequence of values where
all the elements have the same type.
The first example here
is a list of three booleans: False True
and False.
You see here that we denote to type
with colon colon and then the type
is list of Bool. One of the nice
features of Haskell
that the syntax of types, you see here
the syntax
of types, sorry the syntax of values here
on the left, looks very similar to the
syntax of types on the right.
We use the same square brackets to
indicate a list of values and we
used the same
square brackets to indicate the type so
False True False has type Bool
The second example there has a type, has a
list
of characters a b c d and its type is a
list of character
and that's just the same as String.
In general
the rule is that [t]
list of t denotes the type of lists
with elements of type t.
Note that the type of the list
doesn't say anything about its length.
If we have the list False True it has type
list of Bool
and if we have the value False
True False
it also has type Bool
and also the types of these
elements can be arbitrary as long as they're
all the same.
The last example down here
has a slightly more complicated type:
It's a list
of lists of characters. That's what
you see here:
list of list of characters and if you
look at the value
you see that it contains two lists
of characters. The thing with the list is
that
all the elements must have the same type
but the length is
unrestricted. Compare and contrast that
with tuples.
A tuple there
the type contains the length but the
values the types of values can be
different
so the first example here that's a
tuple of two booleans, True and False.
There you see that the type is Bool, Bool.
It's not the list, if it would be a list, the type
would be list of Bool,
but in this case it's a tuple of
two booleans
True and False and the type is Bool, Bool.
Now the second example has type
Bool, Char, Bool
and what you see here is that it
contains three values
one is a boolean, the second one
is a character and the third one is
a boolean again
and that's reflected in the type.
In general
if we have a tuple of type t1 to
tn
that's the type of a tuple that has
n values
of each respective type t1 up to tn.
The type of a tuple
encodes its size so True False or
False True there has type Bool, Bool.
You see there the length
of this tuple is reflected in the type.
Second on there there's three booleans
so we see that the tuple has three
booleans and the type of the values
is unrestricted, so they can be mixed
and matched. In this case we have a
tuple
that contains a character
and then as the second value a tuple
that has a boolean and a character
and then the last example there is a tuple
that has a boolean and then a list of
characters
You see, there is a boolean here, a boolean
True
and a list of 'a', 'b' and we see that the type
there
is Bool and a list of Char.
This is the end of part one
about types and next we'll talk about
functions since we're dealing with the
functional language
functions are very important so we'll
spend
a little bit of time zooming into
functions. Thank you
and see after the break